let's say you're a new private pilot and
you just finished up all your training
in an airplane with analog flight
instruments are you required to take
some kind of training in order to fly an
airplane with digital flight instruments
if you said no you're right but there
are some things you should be aware of
before you jump in that cockpit and take
off
digital flight instruments or as i like
to call them glass cockpits come in all
different shapes and sizes but as a
general rule these are usually broken up
into three main components the first of
which is the primary flight display also
known as the pfd information that you'd
receive here is the same information
that you would traditionally receive
from the six primary flight instruments
or the six pack in just a second we'll
talk about how to interpret what you're
looking at on the pfd
but for now let's look at the other two
parts one of these is the multi-function
display also known as the mfd the mfd
can display a lot of different types of
information one of these is navigation
information kind of like the moving map
you see here these can also display
engine data traffic information weather
and a lot more in fact on some mfds at
the push of a button they can also
become a primary flight display which
can be pretty handy if you lose your pfd
for one reason or another and this
brings me to the third part of our glass
cockpit the standby flight instruments
these include the airspeed indicator the
attitude indicator the altimeter and the
magnetic compass and if you're a
subscriber to the free pilot training
channel you're probably an expert on all
these by now
okay so let's go back and take a closer
look at the primary flight display all
the information that you're used to
seeing is still here it's just in a
little bit different spot than what
you're used to
for example take a look over here at the
airspeed indicator instead of seeing the
round dial you're used to we're seeing
something now called an airspeed tape
and this thing's super nice because it
slides up and down to give your exact
air speed as you're flying and notice
this thing's also color coded like the
old fashioned ones and these help you
identify safe air speeds to fly at in
different configurations and if you
don't know what those are i've got a
video that goes into a lot more detail
on that next if you take a quick glance
over here at the altimeter you'll notice
that it's also a tape and your altimeter
setting should be attached to this thing
somewhere as you can see here it's at
the bottom of the tape but in addition
to that most of these have a place where
you can set a specific altitude in most
cases this setting will allow the
airplane to alert the pilot once you
reach your desired altitude if the
airplane has autopilot installed this
can also be used to hold your altitude
next we have the vertical speed
indicator and these are usually right
next to the altimeter on these things
and as you can see this guy's also a
tape then over here we have the attitude
indicator as you can probably tell this
thing looks really similar to the old
gauges but it's a lot easier to read and
just like the old ones these still give
you the same indications of pitch and
bank but you'll probably notice that
these are a lot smoother and they give a
lot more accurate readings down here you
might have noticed that the miniature
aircraft is a little bit different than
what you're used to seeing if you don't
like the new airplane some of these
allow you to change it out for the old
water line let's zoom in just a little
bit on the new bank indicator underneath
this triangle is a little bar this is
your slip skid indicator and it replaces
your old ball
so when you get those left to right side
forces you step on the bar now instead
of the ball now let's take a look down
here at the new heading indicator just
like the old one this guy tells us our
magnetic heading but in addition to that
you probably already noticed that it
also gives us some navigation
information when it combines this data
like this we call this a horizontal
situation indicator this particular hsi
is tuned into a vor but a lot of
airplanes can display even more than
that this particular airplane has a gps
tied to it then up here above the hsi
you'll find the turn indicator and this
is how we'd know if we were in a
standard rate turn or a half standard
rate turn
do you remember what that is comment
below if you do so how do all these
things work let's take a quick look at
that first we'll take a look at what
traditionally would have been the
gyroscopic instruments if you can't
remember what those are those are the
attitude indicator the heading indicator
and the turn indicator these instruments
get their information from something
called the attitude and heading
reference system this thing is basically
a small box with a bunch of sensors
inside a couple of these sensors are
called accelerometers and rate gyros
these sense pitch and bank the aher
system then takes this data and sends it
over to the attitude indicator and the
turn indicator another type of sensor
inside of the ahers is a magnetometer
these sends the earth's magnetic field
vector to determine the magnetic heading
of your airplane the ahers system then
sends this data over to the primary
flight display so you can read the
information on the heading indicator and
the best part about this whole system is
that it eliminates compass errors which
means you don't have to update your
heading indicator anymore in flight
another one of these fancy electrical
boxes on these new airplanes is called
an air data computer this guy takes
dynamic air pressure from the pedo tube
and static air from the static port and
converts it into information that the
pilot can use then it takes that
information and sends it over to the pfd
so it can be read on the airspeed
indicator the altimeter and the vertical
speed indicator one cool thing about the
air data computer is that it also
includes temperature sensors and this
allows it to give you your true air
speed in flight to check to make sure
the air data computer works properly
during each pre-flight you should blow
into the pitot tube until you hear this
message
okay
i'm just kidding don't actually do that
it actually says not to do that here on
the air data computer so why do i care
about these two systems well if you get
these big red x's across your air speed
indicator your altimeter and your
vertical speed indicator then you know
you have a failed air data computer
but if i have big red x's across my
attitude indicator my turn indicator and
my hsi then i know i have a failed ahers
system and that's really going to help
me in an emergency because when i pull
out the poh i'll know which piece of
equipment to troubleshoot and if that
fails i've still got the trusty old
standby flight instruments which are not
required in vfr conditions but they are
when you're flying ifr look how easy it
was to knock out a little bit of
studying smash that like button and keep
the trend going with this video right
here
[Music]